welcome to this video playing for phony
this albania hong kong SAR china albania
what do they have and it's also
something red right I'm sorry if I'm
confusing things here okay yeah I need
to I want to really want to get some of
my rating back here there was some time
losses are frustrating really when you
completely dominate the whole game and
and lose on time and it totally from
totally winning position throughout and
it's mostly those losses that hurt the
rating I mean I don't let's see what I
can do in this yell then I would Indian
type of position yes the bishop on g4
though this is an interesting idea had
this one's in the tournament game try to
get a night to f5 Guiche of age 59 f 5
this is not the end of the world for
black but it's a good piece there and it
is some nice space advantage that white
has can even think about taking their
only seven
hmm I wonder it's not totally totally
clear to me what is the right way to
play him I even d5 comes into
consideration not easy I think he has to
go see five here no choice really and
then I've thought that like G for fys
just gaining lots of space ok possibly
following up with that phone the problem
is a little bit that he has difficulties
with expelling this night what you can
do is age 6 Bishop yada sir Knight h7
and things like that but it's still a
use huge advantage in space so let's
let's get this n
okay interesting yeah if I take with the
Jeep on that sleeves my epon and a very
vulnerable state so i will take with the
upon it also makes my bishop a little
bit more active a little bit but this is
not a problem with the bad bishop or
anything I have so much advantage in
space that it's it's totally okay okay
so he wants to get this in Bishop g5 how
interesting can go night you for yeah
let's do that spending a bit too much
time here again this position will be
better for whites in any case and since
it's not really a matter of precise
moves here so it's it's probably totally
okay to be relatively quick about it and
just play one of the good moves and go
from there until except that it's
probably not the absolute best one every
time another what I want here is
probably something like a minor piece
and gammas would be brilliant with the
bishop pair and the huge space advantage
trading off all major all heavy pieces
would be fantastic a queen d to look you
want look at you and just just trying to
exchange everything on the e-file and
you will suffer in this end game forever
jun 4 p-5
okay i can i can go here I mean you
probably can still play be five for a
pawn sack or something but discouraging
it is it's not a bad idea the Queen on
d3 is not badly placed anyway oops I
have to check the door
oh wow this wasn't good losing this time
it was something delivered no checks no
chess books this time okay so i can not
far behind on the clock at least could
be worse so we did get in b5 okay so who
could be for those kind of moves Queen a
form can be they can get some activity
there but if I'm doubling on the e-file
it's something that he probably cannot
easily ignore
yeah as mentioned I'd like to trade
trade team even rook be one here is
possible at you and I have the holy fog
covered so trading here is good I think
yeah I still lost quite some time there
I would have even had a time advantage
if it wasn't for the for the other for
the delivery men with the this package
coming ok it's good that he's spending
some time here ok so i can trade now in
there we'll just to make sure that i
won't get any problems on the king with
the time running down night if form is
the next more no it's not preventing it
that's good getting the bishop over
yeah Black is in big trouble he has a
hard time to move any PCM check I treat
you a little ok so is preparing Knight
f6 maybe I'm hi morning night have six
some way to fight against this idea I
don't see it at the moment 92 to f3
maybe I don't know if this is helping me
it's it's it's actually not a bad idea
it's not a bad regrouping I it's got 95
or this move man that wasn't good oh no
I was a bad idea ok i jested Bishop g5
it's still quite nice but not as nice as
it could have been that was a bad play
really bad play by boyd check
not terrible I did Wow losing this is
like a disgrace yeah really a disgrace
come on draw don't want to win this on
time check okay yeah well they're not we
know anti-black foreheads on cannot do
more than offer draw him Wow Jatakas
stadium I mean it was like completely
outplayed here and I overlooked this
Bishop g5 here which was really silly
check another really stupid idea 92 was
totally stupid here why this is just in
control it's not so easy to learn to win
but it's just very nice for me the
question is what exactly is the best way
to play this is good a5 Bishop a FOIA
this is a good move I was only thinking
about Bishop f4 immediately but this is
strong the point is even if he does
something like that yeah I would still
play this move and he cannot afford to
take here I guess I think this should be
a big problem in the long run this is
super strong yeah it's very strong and
if he takes hear this and I'm still
doing this regrouping I have to do this
first and then again the bishop the
bishop maneuver alice is like a torture
to player maybe can hold it yeah it
sometimes possible even if it looks like
totally passive but maybe you can hold
it like here and then here this is a
typical end game that can happen from
the arabic other buck variation of the
king's indian this very one sided
endgame yeah I don't know maybe he can
somehow hole that yeah it's it's very
very unattractive but maybe he can hold
it my g8 Bishop f4 Kings is so I don't
know well at the end I I mean this is my
my way of doing things ever win in a
totally lost position i offer a draw and
if he doesn't take it it's nothing that
I can do I mean I don't know I really
don't feel like I should resign it
especially like a lost 20 seconds or so
when I when I had to answer the door I
would have had much more time on the
clock otherwise and maybe I wouldn't
even have made this mistake when he got
in Bishop g5 you never know we are but I
mean I think a draw is a fair azhagiya
he's winning on position i'm winning on
time so why not you know in an increment
time control where we don't have this
kind of rationale we just would continue
the game but some way need some way to
resolve this okay well thanks for
watching